France loves French,
it's quite possible.
There's no other country on earth
this proud of its linguistic heritage.
So in light of the attacks just days ago,
perhaps there's no tribute to Paris,
more Parisian and spending some time
grammar checking. Isis is French.
Well, the world takes in the
shock of the Paris attacks.
News comes in from friends telling us
there's a letter from the Islamic state
claiming full responsibility and
in perfect French, nonetheless,
always eager to justify my underused
degree in romance languages.
I had to see what counts is
perfect French these days.
Tracking down an image of the
communique in just a few clicks.
I it and prepared to read my way through
what I would sure would be a brief
declaration of religious
war against the infidels.
Perfectly polished by some middlemen
translator giving me that stellar French I
was promised and at first I think I got
what I expected or religious dedication,
sacred versa and
explanation of the attacks.
But handful of sentences in some
linguistic doubts bubbled up. Yes,
mandatory references
to align the caliphate,
but wanting humiliating his enemies.
You mean wanting to humiliate?
Okay.
A La has conquered by their hand and to
cast fear in the heart of the Crusaders
we was all that has conquered by their
handed has cast fear in the heart of the
Crusaders. Okay. This is actually
a pretty common mistake that I see.
These are actually homogenous and French,
so maybe that makes some sense,
but it's definitely not polished.
The bet that canal or hundreds of
idolaters we're gathered where hundreds of
idolaters,
not to mention the buttock loan is all
small like it's a familiar place in the
city and not a proper noun.
Sometimes I don't even know who you'd be.
Nuances at tech,
the result of his attacks.
Did you misspell visa tax?
Is this talking about their attacks,
but you used the singular
instead of the plural?
Did you get confused by just having
mentioned say clue? It's streets.
The streets of Paris and the previous
sentence, I can't tell since.
See here,
granted them what they were hoping for.
The martyr martyrdom
may all I accept them.
I'm on the martyrs and
they allow us to join them.
He allow by far the parts of this thing
with the lowest linguistic weirdness
factor or the top and bottom verses
from the Koran copied punctuation at all
from as far as I can track it down,
this French translation
by Mohammed Hmi Doula,
a prolific writer and language lover
in his own right, but let's be honest,
it's a good bet.
They were pasted from one of the
free online sites that come up here.
They were even kind enough to start
it off with this same little blessing.
There's so much strangeness to it.
I think some of that linguistic
strangeness pops out in Just One word.
This is the word Suda.
Sarah is a typical feminine known in
Arabic and like so many feminine nouns.
It comes built in with what they
call an attached t in the word Sarah.
That attached talk gives away the gender,
but make a note that tall isn't pronounced
when the word is on its own like this.
Instead,
it's a silent t that shows up in speech
only when the word takes other forms.
Other endings like when it's
the subject of a sentence,
there's a different noun
form for that and Arabic.
And that's where the difference comes
in between the English pronunciation of
this word Sura the Nae devised English
way to pronounce that Arabic word on its
own with the silent t and the
French pronunciation, nuts, Syrah.
But sue hats from the form with the nuts.
So silent t,
but this guy doesn't write the French
word so hot. He writes it this way.
It looks similar to your highs,
but it caught me off guard first.
There's this funny hat,
it's a circumflex.
Vowels often wear that hat is a decorative
piece of French language history.
The leftover crumbs of a French sound
that used to be there but isn't anymore.
The French word beast, for
example, earned itself.
That happened when he got
rid of its s long time ago.
The word for sure in French gained it
circumflex by losing its inner e and
that's after it had already erased.
It's Latins see that it had long ago.
So what sounded Sura
Losing French? Well, none.
There's an even bigger clue here.
There's that missing e at the end,
just like an English. Well,
almost like an English.
The final e can be silent in French,
but that doesn't mean it has
no impact on the language.
It does something to the letter before it.
See,
there are a lot of consonants that just
don't get pronounced when they're at the
end of a French word. It's why as Jack
and blowhole aren't Jackson poor rot,
but when that he makes its way onto
the end of a word with a silent t,
it stays silent. Bull,
the tea gets pronounced.
So in sue got the final,
he lets us have our tea,
but lop off that finally,
and I promise you,
any French reader will
pronounce this as a silent t.
This word is so raw and that's where it
gets strange to see if this righteous
tongue rider is all about French or his
translator on retainer is Sukha is a lot
harder to justify.
But if he's imitating the Arabic
pronunciation of the word in isolation,
Swa suddenly becomes a plausible spelling.
On the other hand,
this spelling isn't at all what I'd
expect if someone were just translating
literally from Arabic.
It shows a familiarity with native Ising
Arabic words into French in a way that
tells us something about the culture
of that native arising process.
Making analogies with other French words
that come to mind and even extending
circumflex is in a standardized academic
way to compensate for that Arabic long
val and it's that Arabic minded circumflex
that makes sense when you consider
two other facts.
One,
the few other examples we can find
touting this spelling our shakes and
institutes citing specific verses in their
lectures or people setting themselves
up as instructors teaching
you something from the Koran,
always leaning into that formal Arabic
even when they're preaching in another
tongue to Islam.
Specifically this way of spelling Islam
this way is leaning into yet another
Arabic long val.
Now,
I don't mean to mislead you into thinking
that this is all a bunch of lurking
Arabic seeping through.
That's not what swipe is telling us.
This isn't the dictionary French word,
but it's not the dictionary
Arabic word either.
This is too productive for a literal
translation for a broader audience,
but it's also to communal for
a case of personal creativity.
And my hunch right now is it, this is
the root of my feeling of strangeness.
This is where the language of
this communique begins to unravel,
giving us a glimpse of the writer as well
as other targets in the 10th the 11th
the 18th Allen Small and
this simultaneously, my
reading's not English enough,
it's too close to the original,
but zoom in here closer.
The writer knows he's about to list a
bunch of targets so it uses the plural,
but then in mid sentence he turns to
break this list up and just three singular
targets and he finishes it all up
with this journalistic. But wait,
there's more back reference tweak.
It's like the first draft of a stop and
go news report tripping over itself and
it's all laced with the
stream of condemnation.
So constant that it's almost as if the
terms were just the only words available
at the time and the mind of the writer,
France and Germany are the two crusader
countries also allowed the idiot of
France. There are miscreants.
There's perversion,
there's a motive wanting and hoping
and shooting and how dare you.
Ing of modal verbs dressed
up as statements of fact
and of course the threat of
more to come would all sound so over
the top if only it weren't so fresh.
This is the product of a
mind that knows French. Yes,
but one that makes linguistic mistakes,
linguistic mistakes that showcase in
idiosyncratic language that's closer to a
certain kind of community speech of a
near of Arabic style and simple full puff
fumblings with political, French
News, announcement delivery.
It's so much closer to those things
than it is to what I was naive promised
would be a clear example
of perfect French,
but maybe my language is too flower.
You're stylized here. This is what I mean.
It's a heat.
He sets himself up as a preacher,
but a preacher that's more easier than,
than meticulous.
And while he is someone that wants
to instruct you, even preach to you,
is this on the scholar a translator?
Even though he likes to incorporate
teaks of religious scholarship,
he's from a subculture that readily
Arab rather than color sizes,
Arabic borrowings into French.
He distances himself from his surroundings
playing both moral judge and factual
reporter.
He knows Punam the city of lights well
enough to be disgusted by specifics,
but he's probably not the translator.
He's the author.
Yeah.